برده ايران من اللجنه الامميه لحقوق
المراه واشنطن تصف القرار بالتاريخ وطهران
تعتبره سياسيا
واشنطن تخطط لتزويد اوكرانيا بمعدات
الكترونيه متطوره تحول الذخائر غير
الموجهه الى ذكيه
احتفالات في فرنسا بتاهل الديوك لنهائي
كاس العالم
واحتفالاته في المغرب بانجازات اسود
الاطلس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره الى اهم
الانباء من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم
بدر
الخارجيه الايرانيه بتعليقه عضويه ايران
في لجنه الامم المتحده المعنيه بوضع
المراه وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان هذا القرار
سياسي وقد اتخذ دون سند قانوني ومخالف
لميثاق الامم المتحده
قلم استشار الامن القومي الامريكي جاك
سلفين ان الامم المتحده اجر التصويت
تاريخيا لطرد ايران من اللجنه المعنيه
بوضع المراه ونقل البيت الابيض في بيان عن
سلفا قوله ان الاداره الامريكيه تعمل مع
حلفائها وشركائها في العالم لمحاسبه ايران
على الانتهاكات التي ترتكبها بحق شعبها
لاسيما المتظاهرين السلميين فضلا عن
اعمالها المزعزي على الاستقرار في انحاء
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وقال سيرفا ان عمليه
الاعدام الاخيره في طهران لن تؤدي الا
لتقويه عزمي بلاده على استخدام جميع
الاليات الممكنه لمحاسبه النظام الايراني
ايران لا تزالوا تلوح بالتهديد والوعيد
لقمع الناشطين بحجه تورطهم باعمال شغب
خلال الاحتجاجات فيما يقولوا وزير
المخابراتها اسماعيل خطيب للنشاطات في
الخارج ان ايران ستلاحقكم وتنزل بكم
العقاب
سيعاقب كل من اضر بالبلاد اينما كان في
العالم وكل شخص متورط في اعمال الشغب
سيعاقب ايضا
مع الفكره
الايراني روح الله زم وايضا بعد تهديدات
الحرس الثوري ضد صحفي ايران انترناشونال
التي اعلنت في الشهر الماضي عن تهديدات
الموثوقه تلقاها صحفيوها من الحرس الثوري
لكن ما هي الوسائل التي تمكن الاستخبارات
الايرانيه من الوصول الى خصومها في الخارج
لدى ايران شبكاته تجسس وازرع في دول
المجاوره بينها تركيا والعراق
لمقيم في فرنسا عام 2019 ايضا اختطف
النظام الايراني خلال السنوات الاخيره
نشطاء بينهما جمشيد شارما هاد وفرج الله
كعب المعروف بحبيب اسيا ود وايضا اختطاف
مدير مجموعه تندر الناشط شارما هاد ذو سته
66 عاما من قبل عملاء ايرانيين خلال رحلته
من المانيا الى الهند في 2020 في المقابل
اخفقت بعده عمليات الاختطاف بينها خليه
اسطنبول حين اعلنت تركيا عن اعتقال اشخاص
مرتبطين بعمليه اختطاف الناشط حبيب اسياده
فيما القى جهاز المخابرات التركيه القبض
على احد عشر شخصا من اعضاء شبكه تهريب
المخدرات التابعه لناجي شريف في زان دشتي
متورطين ايضا في اختطاف اسيا بالاضافه الى
الاشتباه في قيام اعضاء الشبكه بعمليات
تجسس لصالح الحرس الثوري
ملاحقه معارضيه الخارج طبقا معضله
الاساسيه
لسلطات الايرانيه هي احتجاجات الداخل التي
لم تخمد في شهر الثالث
في ايران ايضا قضت السلطات بسجن عامل
الاغاثه البلجيكي اوليفيا فان دي كاستل
مده 28 عاما في الوقت الذي تشدد فيها
عائله وسلطات البلجيكيه على برائته وانه
محتجز كرهينه في اطار جهود طهران للضغط
لاطلاق صلاح الدبلوماسي الايراني اسعد
الله اسد
الاجانب ومززوجوا الجنسيه من ذوي الاصول
الايرانيه حولهم النظام في طهران الى ورقه
ابتزاز تلوح بها امام الحكومات الاجنبيه
اخر هذه الاوراق حكم اصدرته السلطات
الايرانيه يقضي بسجن عامل الاغاثه
البلجيكي اولمبيه فان دي كاستين لمده
ثمانيه وعشرين عاما بعد اعتقاله في فبراير
الماضي بتهمه التجسس وهي الاتهامات التي
تنفيها السلطات البلجيكيه وعائله المدان
بقوه بلجيكا ترى في قضيه عامل الغذاء
والحكم الصادر في حقه وسيله ضغط ايراني
على بلجيكا لاطلاق سراح الدبلوماسيه
الايراني اسد الله اسد المحكوم ب 20 سنه
بالسجن في بلجيكا على خلفيه ادانته
بالتخطيط لهجوم على تجمعا للمعارضه
الايرانيه في فرنسا عام 2018 خطوه ايرانيه
تاتي بعد اسبوع من تعليق المحكمه
الدستوريه في بلجيكا معاهده لتبادل
السجناء مع ايران والتي يعتبر ان يصدر
الحكم النهائي في مدى شرعيتها خلال ثلاثه
اشهر معتبره محللون انه رد غاضب من ايران
بعد هذا التعليق وان كان مؤقتا
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه عن
مسؤولين قولهم ان الولايات المتحده تخطط
لارسال معدات الكترونيه متطوره الى
اوكرانيا تحول الذخائر غير موجهه الى
قنابل ذكيه
يبحث قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماعهم
ببروكسل اليوم تطورات حرب اوكرانيا
والازمه الايرانيه وازمه ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه ومخاطر دخول الاتحاد مرحله ركوب
خطير مصادر العربيه قالت ان الدول
الاوروبيه عده طلبه بحث دعم ايران لروسيا
في حرب اوكرانيا وقال رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي ان القمه ستبحث وسائل واليات
تامين دعم اوكرانيا بصفه مستدامه على جميع
الاسيد السياسيه والاقتصاديه والعسكريه
والانسانيه
اعلنا دبلوماسيان غربيان ان روسيا مارست
ضغوطا كبيرا على الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو بيوترش ومستشاريه لعدم
فتح تحقيق بخصوص ارسال ايران طائرات مسيره
لموسكو لاستخدامها في حرب اوكرانيا حسب ما
ذكر موقع اكسيوس لكن وفقا للدبلوماسيه
الغربيين فان المستشار القانوني للامم
المتحده ووكيله الشؤون السياسيه مصممان
على تفويض جوتيرش بتكليف خبراء لبحث امر
ارسال الطائرات المسيره الى روسيا وشراء
الى وجود ثوابقه من حالات مماثله في الشرق
الاوسط
حضر الكريم من ان القوات الروسيه ستستهدف
منظومه صواريخ باتريوت التي سترسلها
واشنطن الى اوكرانيا فيما اوضح خبراء
عسكريون وامنيون ان العالم لم يشهد اي
استهدافا لمنظومه صواريخ
اوكرانيا تترقب وصول منظومه الصواريخ
باتريوت خلال ايام كما وعدتها واشنطن
والكريملين يهدد باستهدافها
ارسال واشنطن صواريخ باتريوت الى اوكرانيا
سيدفع بقوتنا الى استهدافها باعتبارها
اهدافها مشروعه روسيا حذرت من توسيع
الصراع بسبب تدخل واشنطن من خلال تزويد
اوكرانيا
موسكو بالتصعيد والمساعده في تقديم تلك
الصواريخ رغم محاوله الحلف تجنب المواجهه
مع موسكو لكن ربما يتسائل البعض كيف يمكن
لروسيا ان تستهدف منظومه الصواريخ باتريوت
والعالم لم يشهد بعد ان استهداف لتلك
المنظومه
خبراء وعسكريون اكدوا للعربيه ان روسيا لا
يمكنها استهدافه صواريخ باتريوت تحت اي
ظرف خاصه خلال نصب المنظومه الذي يتم بحذر
شديد تحت غطاء جوي كثير يتم تهيئه
المنظومه في مكان بعيد عن اعين الروس ثم
تنقل بعدها الى مسرح العمليات لتفعلها
اوكرانيا ستستخدم صواريخ باتريوت للتصدي
للصواريخ الروسيه الباريسيه بينها اسكندر
لان كياف اصبح لديها اربعه انظمه دفاع
جويه حصلت عليها من فرنسا وبريطانيا و
بولندا بالاضافه الى اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه ما يعني انك لديها نظام دفاع جوي
فريد في نوعه على مستوى العالم من اوروبا
واسيا وامريكا
كيف ستعمل هذه المنظومه التي تعول عليها
اوكرانيا
تتكون من ثلاثه اقسام هي رادار بامكانه
كشف واعتراض اي مقاتله او طائره بدون طيار
او صاروخ ضمن دائره اشعاعها اكثر من 100
كلم وهذا ما تبحث عنه كيف
المنظومه لها مركز مراقبه يشغله ثلاثه
عسكريين وبطاريه من الصواريخ الاعتراضيه
لصد ايها هجمات صواريخ باتريوت ستكون ايضا
عنصرا اساسيا لحمايه الاراضي الاخرانيه
على الجناح الشرقيه ضمن نطاق دفاعات
النيته
ستنشر منظومه باتريوت في مناطق شرقي وجنوب
شرقي اوكرانيا لصد صواريخ روسيا التي
تنطلق من بحر ازوف في الجنوب الشرقي
والبحر الاسود جنوبي اوكرانيا
امريكي
واعطاء البيت الابيض الضوء الاخضر س وشحنه
صواريخ باتريوت الى اوكرانيا وتدريب
عناصرها على استخدامها في قاعده للجيش
الامريكي في المانيا
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الكنديه ميلاني جولي
ان كندا الغت الاعفاء المحدود من العقوبات
الذي تم منحه لروسيا من اجل سماح لها
بالاستعانه بشركه سننزل للطاقه الاصلاحيه
تربنات خط انابيب نور ستريم واحد واوضح
جولي في تغريده عبر تويتر ان الرئيس
الروسي سبق ان اقر بان خط الانابيب اصبح
غير صالحا للعمل
وانهانيت لديه لاصلاح
نشاطنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد الفاصل
تفاصيل جديده عن مؤامره الانقلاب في
المانيا نيويورك تايمز تكشف عن ادله جديده
تربط روسيا بالمخطط الذي احبطته برلين
اهلا بكم من جديد انتهت مباراه المنتخب
المغربي ضد نظيره الفرنسي بهدفين نظيفين
لصالح منتخب الديوك في نصف النهائي فيما
يواجه المنتخب الفرنسي نظيره الارجنتيني
في المباراه النهائيه يوم الاحد يلاقي
اسود الاطلس كرواتيا يوم السبت لتحديد
المركزين الثالث والرابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الان المزيد من التفاصيل حول اخبار
المونديال في هذه
النشره اللي عبد الله الدرويش
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الى مو جزء الرياضي
حمله الدفاع عن اللقب لمنتخب فرنسا تستمر
بعد فوزه على نظيره المغربي بهدفين دون رد
ليضرب موعدا كبيرا مع الارجنتين في نهائي
كاس العالم الاحد المقبل على ملعب روسيا
ونجح المنتخب الفرنسي بتسجيل الهدف الاول
عند الدقيقه الخامسه عبر فيو هيرنانديز
اتمكن المنتخب المغربي من امتلاك الكره في
معظم اوقات
محاولا تسجيل هدف التعادل لكنه لم ينجح
بذلك حتى سجل المنتخب الفرنسي ثاني اهداف
عبر البديل رانده في الدقيقه التاسعه
والسبعين لتنتهي بذلك مشاركه المنتخب
التاريخيه في المونديال المسجلان افضل
انجاز عربي وافريقيا بالوصول الى نصف
النهائي ومازال يملك فرصه الحصول على
المرتبه الثالثه
في مباراه تحديد المركزين الثالث
واتجه وليد الرجراجي ولاعبوه الى الجماهير
ويتبادلات تحيه والتصفيق بعد الظهور
المشرف في هذه البطوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قام الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون بزياره
الى سوق واقف في الدوحه قبل ساعات من
مباراه بلاده امام المغرب في نصف نهائي
مونديال قطر قبل ان يتوجه الى الملعب
لمتابعه مجريات اللقاء
ايوه ايوه
[موسيقى]
بدا منتخب كرواتيا استعداداته لمباراه
المركز الثالث التي ستقام السبت المقبل
وقام قائد المنتخب مودريتش ببعض التمارين
الخفيفه خلال التدريبات مع استمراري تزايد
التكهنات بشان مستقبله الدولي ولم يستطع
المدرب السابق قزلاتكو داليتش تاكيدا ما
اذا كان صانع الالعاب سيقرر الاعتزال بعد
مباراه تحديد المركز الثالث وقال ان
العالم باسره سيبتقده في حال قرر الاعتزال
ميسي كان على الموعد امام مكروه سجل هدفا
وصنعه اخرا وهو من قاد الهجمه في الهدف
الثاني لزميله الفارس اعدنا الى اجواء 86
وتنتظر المباراه النهائيه عله يزيد بعض
الارقام
قبل مباراتك كرواتيا بالدوري النصف
النهائي رفرف قميصه عاليا في سماء مدينه
ميسي الى النهائي
ميسي كان في الموعد امام كرواتيا سجل هدفا
وصنع اخر وهو من قاد الهجمه في الهدف
الثاني لزميله الفريس
نجم باريس سان جيرمان بهدفه في مرمى
كرواتيا تمكن من الانفرادي بصداره
الهدافين التاريخيين للارجنتين في
النهائيات باحد عشر هدفنا بعدما تقاسمها
خلال الايام الماضيه مع باتيستوتا صاحب ال
10 اهداف
صاحب الرقم القياسي كاكثر اللاعبين مشاركه
في نهائيات كاس العالم بعدما تقاسم الرقم
في مباراه كرواتيا مع الالمانيوس صاحب
الخمس والعشرين مشاركه في البطوله
العالميه
الفينال كاميرا واو كاميرا
السابقه والذي يلعب المونديال الخامس مع
التانجو والاخير في مسيرته الكرويه
ظهر هذه المره بشخصيه مخالفه عن مشاركته
السابقه داخل وخارج الملعب
لفت الانذار وجعل الارجنتينيين يتفائلون
اكثر باللقب الغائب عن خزائنهم منذ
مونديال مكسيكو 86 بعد ما حملوها في وقت
سابق مسؤوليتك كل اخفاء
ما اشبه اجواء مونديال 86 لارجنتين بقياده
مارادونا ومونديال قطر الذي يسير فيه رفاق
ميسي بخطى ثابته نحو وضع النجمه الثالثه
على القميص الابيض والازرق
فهل ينجح ميسي في قياده الارجنتين لرفع
الكاس ام تستمر الخيبه لاربع سنوات مقبله
ما زالتفاصيل المؤامره التي كانت تحاك
بالمانيا تتكشف فقد كشف شخصان مطلعان على
التحقيق لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن وجود
ادله جديده تكشف علاقه روسيا بالمؤامره
الانقلابيه التي احبطتها السلطات
الالمانيه
ادله جديده تكشف علاقه روسيا بالمؤامره
الانقلابيه التي كانت تستهدف الاطاحه
بالحكومه والنظام الالماني
فالمتهم بتنظيم هذه المؤامره التقى مع
دبلوماسيين روس في قنصليه بالمانيا مره
واحده على الاقل
تفاصيل مثيره كشف عنها شخصان مطلعان على
التحقيق بشكل مباشر لصحيفه نيويورك
مرتين القنصليه الروسيه وحده هذه الزياره
كانت في يونيو وتحديدا في اليوم الذي
يصادف العيد الوطني الروسي
كما تمت مصادرته حوالي 40 سلاحا ناريا في
ظل هذه المداهمه التي استهدفت الشبكه
وذلك من خلال 150 موقعا مختلفا في جميع
انحاء البلاد
فضلا عن وجود مخزونات الذخيره الاخرى التي
لم يحدد موقعها بعد
وهو الامر الذي جعل السلطات الالمانيه
تبحث عن مخابئ هذه الاسلحه سلسله
المداهمات اسفرت ايضا عن توقيع اكثر من
100 اتفاقيه عدم ابشاء المعلومات والتي
اقسم الموقعون من خلالها على السريه
التامه بشان خطط الجماعه الذين يدعون
انفسهم بمواطن الرايه فمن بين الاسئله
المفتوحه ليس فقط مخابئ الاسلحه ولكن هناك
ايضا الاثار المترتبه على العديد من
القوائم التي تم العثور عليها باسماء
الاشخاص فيها
اعضاء هذه المجموعه الذين يدعمون هنرش في
انقلابه نشيطون في الجيش والشرطه
وتلقى عدد منهم تدريبات على هذه الاسلحه
وفقا للصحيفه الامريكيه اما فيما يتعلق
بخطه هذه الشبكه الانقلابيه فتضمنت اقتحام
البرلمان الالماني
وصولا الى اعتقال اعضائه كما ان المستشار
الالماني يعد الابرز على قائمه الاغتيالات
كما ضبط المحققون صوره تم التقاطها
بالهواتف المحموله لاحد المتهمين بالتامر
والتي توفق الحواجز المختلفه في احدى
المباني التي تضم مكاتب اعضاء البرلمان
وزاره العدل كشفت بدورها عن قائدين
مفترضين لهذه المجموعه الانقلابيه الاول
الامير هاريش الذي يعتقد انه العقل المدبر
للانقلاب الفاشل
اما الثاني فهو مقدم سابق في الجيش
الالماني ترك عمله في نهايه التسعينات بعد
ما خرق قانون الاسلحه ولا تزال التفاصيل
غامضه في ما يتعلق ببقيه اعضاء المجموعه
فالشرطه الالمانيه القى القبض على 23
مشتبها وتحقق مع واحد 31 شخصا اخرين حتى
الان سلطان العربيه
اذا مشاهدينا في الاخبار العاجله زلزال
بقوه 6.2 على مقياس ريختر يضربوا تايوان
يتواصل اضراب عمال السكك الحديد في
بريطانيا اليوم الثاني على التوالي مع
دخول عمال البريد على خط الاضرابات وذلك
للمطالبه بزياده الاجور وتحسين الظروف
العمل
القياسيه كما يدخل قطاع التمريض هذا
الاسبوع في اول اضراب عام من نوعه وتعقد
الحكومه اجتماعات طارئه لمناقشه كيفيه
التخفيف من تداعيات موجه الاضرابات
الحاليه
ما كانت لندن تخرج من ازمه الازدحام
والاعطال الفنيه التي لحقت بوسائل نقلها
بسبب الثلوج حتى بدات مرحله فوضى جديده
تتسبب بها هذه المره اضرابات السكك
الحديديه التي يصل عددها الى ثمانيه
اضرابات في ديسمبر ويناير فقط ناهيكا عن
الاضرابات الاخرى التي تشهدها قطاعات
مختلفه
رفضعه 64% من اعضاء هيئه السكك الحديديه
عرض الحكومه القاضي بزياده رواتبهم بنسبته
5% هذا العام وعرضا اخر برفعها من جديد
بنسبه 4% خلال العام المقبل وياتي اضراب
وقطاع الممرضين ليزيد من ازمه الاضطرابات
في البلاد مع اضراب الممرضين يومين خلال
ديسمبر مطالبين برفع اجورهم بنسبه تفوق
ونسبه التضخم وهي تكاليف تقول الحكومه
انها لا يمكن تحملها
ماشي
معارض على هذه الحكومه بدلا من اظهار
قيادته سوناك يلعب بصحه الناس وهناك تكلفه
بشريه
[موسيقى]
فعليه ان يقول ذلك اذا كان يعتقد ان
الاضرابات صائبه وان هناك قدره على تلبيه
المطالب عليه ان يقول ذلك
الاخرون اضرابا جديدا سيؤدي الى تاخيرات
في التوصيلات المنزليه ما يعني ان الشهر
هذا قد يكون الاقصى على بريطانيا منذ اكثر
من 10 سنوات
بريطانيا وحكومتها ربما تكون تحت الاختبار
الاصعب فالمقيمون هنا سائم كثره الاضرابات
التي تعطل امورهم اليوميه في مواسم
الاعياد اكثر المواسم ازدحاما ومن المفترض
انها اكثر المواسم فرحا لكن الفرحه تحولت
لكابوس للبعض الذين اتعبتهم كثره
الاضرابات من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي
ايران من اللجنه الامميه لحقوق المراه
واشنطن تصف القرار بتاريخ وطهران تعتبره
سياسيه
واشنطن تخطط لتثبيت اوكرانيا بمعدات
الكترونيه متطوره تحول الذخائر غير
الموجهه الى ذكيه
احتفالات في فرنسا بتاخد الديوك لنهائي
كاس العالم واحتفالات في المغرب بانجازات
اسود الاطلس
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]